peu
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais la mémoire elle messieurs petits
garçons et petites filles bon soir ne
m'en veuillez pas si je vole quelques
secondes sur sept heures de piste aux
étoiles c'est simplement parce qu'il est
normal que je vous remercie d'être
fidèles devant vos pauses de télévision
pour participer à cette heure de cirque
donc place au cirque et surtout place à
celui qui va nous donner le menu de ces
réjouissances d'une heure notre
chambellan notre clown blanc sergio
monsieur sergio approche et vous voulez
vous nous dire chez remettre mon
chirurgie aujourd'hui nous avons cinq
tigres deux lions indomptables quatre
chimpanzés 3 dresseur à cheval un chien
cette sauteur de perchistes trois
magiciens deux augustes un clown blanc
14 musiciens cet acrobate un monsieur
loyal un chef d'orchestre et un port au
parfum apport au parfum c'est un plat
chinois son coin mais non un peu au
parfum c'est la traduction en français
de hong kong hong kong ça veut dire pour
au parfum ça veut dire poireau parfois
elle est alors les artistes qui vont
venir maintenant sur cette piste arrive
de hong kong
j'arrive de hong kong qu'est ce qu'est
ce qu'ils font sont acrobates à son des
acrobates chinois et ça se dit d'être
son compte ça qu'est exactement et son
compte saké coule fallait
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
c'est
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
que peut-on peuple cope
ouais
[Musique]
coc
m
[Musique]
compétente
et
que non
en tant qu'homme
tous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
en
[Musique]
ah ah
tous
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
non
[Musique]
à
mais
non
[Musique]
tous
non
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
on
[Musique]
non
oh
[Musique]
eh bien chers amis nous sommes très très
heureux ce soir de vous présenter un
numéro de haute école un grand numéro de
haute école ce qui se passe mais qu'est
ce que tu fais là tu en prends ton micro
là je vais là j'ai l'intention de monter
une petite école d'équitation c'est très
à la mode à l'heure actuelle alors je
viens faire un peu de publicité pour
avoir des élèves
pourquoi tu crois ont trouvé ici des
ailes ben pourquoi pas il vaut mieux
avoir des élèves avant qu'après alors
qu'il veut devenir l'élève de roger
lanzac voilà c'est simple à bâtir la
voix de monsieur venez monsieur meunier
ya monsieur venir l'applaudir
roger lanzac avoue le manège monsieur
merci beaucoup bonjour monsieur comment
vous appelez-vous michel michel mon cher
michel vous êtes un homme courageux à
vous l'avez bien applaudi au moins il le
mérite
alors écoutez monsieur pour vous soyez
en pleine sécurité on va vous mettre
bien évidemment la ceinture la longe et
ensuite eh bien vous prendrez votre élan
je pense qu'on pourrait peut-être les
demoiselles
ah oui parce aussi l'année de la femme
alors je pense qu'il ya certainement
permis vous une future de mes élèves
oui une très jolie demoiselle la
mademoiselle vous n'avez pas la queue de
cheval mais vous avez de quoi la faire
alors venez nous montrer si vous n'êtes
qu'à bois là elle ne se fait pas prier
demoiselle courageuse donnez moi la
mademoiselle la lah à monsieur michel et
quel est votre prénom mademoiselle
mademoiselle
quel est votre prénom véronique et bien
voilà environics monsieur ça y est c'est
en pleine forme mon cher michel alors
vous allez prendre votre élan n'est ce
pas vous courez et vous sautez sur le
cheval et je tiens à vous dire qu'il y
aura une prime spéciale j'offrirai une
prime spéciale pour celui qui arrivera à
se mettre debout sur le cheval est à
genoux et de vous un la cour michel
allons-y attention vous êtes prêts allez
michel hallé michel alesi rial et
michele rachel et dont michel michel ça
va oui non c'est pas grave il s'étale
étage au-dessus 1
voilà vous souhaitez un petit peu plus
loin voilà un tout petit peu plus haut
allez hop
ça c'est un étage trop essayé de choisir
le milieu côté le mieux c'est que sergio
vous aident à monter ça ira beaucoup
plus voilà monsieur la voile très bien
voilà aimait beaucoup hélas chez le
cheval mon cher franco voilà monsieur
maintenant après ce petit tombeau et
vous mettra tout à genoux
attention
[Musique]
et
m
[Musique]
à
e
oh
m
sa part d'émotion non
un autre monsieur lavaud à un autre
volontaire monsieur la malade madame a
pas l'air de vouloir non vous n'allez
pas vous disputez voudrions pas être
madame ne veut pas et monsieur prouver
votre autorité
rien à faire alors monsieur ben écoutez
en attendant madame ceux des sites va te
blesser monsieur se se conduire en héros
quand même fait quelque chose rien à
faire mais côté on va y avait rhône hic
est déjà prête
oui c'est pas c'est pas la gaine à votre
taille
elle est mince alors ma chère véronique
que vous avez vu un petit peu on va pas
vous faire courir son va pas faire le
court et de jolies demoiselles
vous allez mettre le pied dans la voix
la up
merci attention attention
ah bon ben moi j'ai pour l'instant ça se
passe très bien auj
voilà
un homme se ravisant mais on dirait une
étoile filante
c'est super
m
bravo mesdames et messieurs dans un
numéro de tremplin bascule enfin d'un
numéro de bascule
il y à un sauteur il y à un voltigeur et
il y à un porteur qui rattrape le
voltigeur et bien dans ce numéro c'est
exceptionnel puisqu'il y à un sauteur
qui est en même temps celui qui rattrape
la voltigeuse pour la première fois en
france et pour la première fois la piste
aux étoiles un grand colombien de
charmantes mexicaine orlando et céline
as
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ans
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ans
on
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
oui
[Musique]
oh
vous
[Musique]
oh
pour
oui
[Musique]
oh
à
papa
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça suffit la maison ce que tu me
demandes en présence d'un jeune âge
parce que mon fils quand il était à
l'école quand on a demandé ce que je
faisais dans la vie il disait mon père y
fait le singe ça fait deux années de ça
je suis certain qu'il y a une chose que
tu ne savais pas c'est qu'il si il y à
des singes qui sont animateurs c'est pas
possible si tu vas voir maintenant mais
la relève est assurée parfaitement de
son cher ami merci
alors pour une fois je vais aller s'est
présenté mais moi je valais un
spectateur attend va présenter ses
petits camarades en attend pas moi pas
moi il va présenter ses petits camarades
les chasseurs
oh
[Musique]
non
ah ah
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
entre
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
où
[Applaudissements]
en
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bon
pour
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cette cire qui sont avides d'innovation
il est incontestable que les recherches
spatiales ont permis quand même quelques
recherches et quelques nouveautés
surtout pour le numéro aérien que vous
allez voir ou une perche fixe est devenu
une sorte de satellites
voici donc deux cosmonautes pas comme
les autres les as thooris
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
ans
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tous
et
[Applaudissements]
oui
[Musique]
et
on
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on
où
[Musique]
bon
et
on
oui
[Applaudissements]
non
oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
et [ __ ] à 16 ans 11 ans il a dressé
104 fauvin pour des dompteurs de sept
pays différents et à 27 ans il est
arrivé à faire suffisamment d'économies
pour acheter les cinq tigres et les deux
lions qu'il présente depuis dans le
monde entier
un grand nom du cirque un grand dresseur
est un grand menteur dit à dorval
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
on
à
[Musique]
où
bon
on
[Musique]
mais non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
on est
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais
[Musique]
mesdames et messieurs vous avez
certainement vu comme moi des tigres
avancé en sautant sur les pattes de
derrière mais je pense que vous n'avez
jamais vu et je ne l'avais jamais vu non
plus un tigre marchands comme vous et
moi grâce au talent de 17h farrell
regardez bien
interview jean serge diot s'est défendu
de fumée au cirque d'hiver
moi oui toi ouais ben n'est pas lui mais
oui mais moi c'est un prétexte d'après
des experts quoi pour te faire à tours
d'illusion non c'est pas possible
j'adore ça et moi voir oh là là on c'est
formidable ah oui tiens moi je
demanderai un tours d'illusion si elle
c'est pas mal m'enfin c'est pas terrible
potter est bien mieux
jean made il est là il est l'agent match
jean made
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
oh
m
et
[Musique]
non
m
[Musique]
ma
non
[Musique]
oh
et
e
[Musique]
mais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
n
m
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
non
ch
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non
on
il
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
bon
[Musique]
m
et
[Musique]
d
mais
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
où
monsieur madame ça me chiffonne ya un
truc là dedans
vous aimeriez connaître ce truc machin
j'aimerais bien de connaître le tour est
joué
est ce que vous ne craignez pas de
pénétrer dans la malle mystérieuse à un
jeu capable de répondre tout seul à la
main dans la main le mystérieux je veux
pas tout seul avec votre partenaire oui
avec votre partenaire à rio et a mon
avis tu es on sait ce que c'est gentil
hein
ce que ses gentils ba1 jose en prie
madame attendez je vais enlever m'avait
ce sera toujours ça de pris
[Musique]
voilà bon ben je la chanterais moi aussi
nancy s'il n'y a pas de raison n'a pas
de raison
[Musique]
on met les cannes là
pour
et maintenant qu'est ce qu'il va se
passer monsieur m'a de fermer le rideau
on ferme la cabine tension et 3 1 2 3 et
après vous ouvrez la malle on ouvre les
cadenas et vous êtes sûr qu'il n'y a
plus personne
c'est pas possible aaa
[Musique]
non non non je veux bien mais monsieur
lonzac monsieur lanzac pas problème
enfin te pencher la malle pencher la
malle manche et la marianne ya une photo
photo dédicacée et une grosse bise pour
hélène margaritis signé saint-roger oui
monsieur matte c'est bien gentil de
l'avoir fait disparaître maintenant
faites le revenir
il a voulu disparaître c'est une chose
faite maintenant en ce qui concerne le
reste là c'est votre problème
alors monsieur madame n'y a pas non
monsieur made
[Musique]
roger roger je suis là où ça paraît dans
la malle comment tuer c'est pas possible
on va l'ouvrir les personnes
mon sens oui matt est matérialisé very
ben oui mais enfin c'est pas possible il
faut faire quelque chose' encore un
numéro un parc immobilier pour moi je
peux rien faire je le pense a tous je le
présente tout seul oui elle était bon et
bien bien je te poser une question
connais-tu la spécialité des indes en
page rappelle quelque chose c'est la
malle aaa est la spécialité de la
hongrie à la hongrie et c'est le paprika
la bascule les sauteurs la bascule
exactement mais les marocains restent
les maîtres incontestés
en tout ce qui concerne le saut et
pyramides vous allez le voir avec la
troupe des dangers
[Musique]
non
mais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
plus
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
eh bien chers amis monsieur ahmed ben va
maintenant porter sur ses épaules ses
six partenaires soit un poids total de
500 kilos avoué bravo monsieur ahmed
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
oh
m
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
comment
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui
[Applaudissements]
là
à
[Musique]
monsieur petits garçons et petites
filles vous venez de voir depuis le
cirque d'hiver bouglione à paris la
piste aux étoiles composé par les
bagarres it is présenté par tonton roger
et moi est accompagné par l'orchestré
bernard hilda avec de très grands et des
grands transferts très grand cloud de
plus
rend d'ailleurs
les falcons
les charmantes ne placerai que de ça toi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et venant de hong kong avec les couleurs
et les jeux qu'on me prouve une fois
finie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le colombien et de ravissantes de poupée
qui saute
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
4' et espiègle chimpanzés en compagnie
de leur maître et ami léché fait
[Musique]
deux étoiles de plus dans le ciel de la
peau
easter à la perche tournante là les *
[Musique]
dresseur et un courageux d'entre eux
pierre forest
oh
chemin magicien
talent
merci de m'avoir abonnés
jean matte
les cinq partenaires
voilà
c'est acrobates marocains qui savent
tout faire et le font bien rangée du
groupe
[Applaudissements]
bien sûr le symbole du cirque de vrai
sirh que mon compère
[Applaudissements]
chef d'atelier
chef de production morse duponchel de
plateau olivier louchard directeur de la
photographie j'en fais pour cadreur
jacques guilliers jean-martin gérard
dollars
[Musique]
yves andré m'a pris deux sont henri
delagnes équipements vidéo henri lamare
et rené c'est fait on a choyé de scop
alain serbie conseiller artistique
medini assistant françois domon script
michel oisillons réalisation jacques
duault
à
[Musique]